it would error checking why would it be
such a big deal and you can see there's
all these different things we have to go
through
in communication systems and you can
think back to yesterday's lesson as well
why would error checking and you know
correcting it as a result
why would it be so important why are we
so needed
any thoughts
okay good so if i want to actually make
sure that the person i'm talking to
gets the right signal okay um here's the
right message reads the right message
then i want to check for errors i don't
want them to think you know that they
said something i didn't
or that they um they made an order
requested an order that i didn't you
know that kind of thing
what else think back to yesterday and
the specifics the physical specifics are
what's involved in communication systems
why would error checking be such an
important thing let's revise
we said there were three kinds of cables
right three kinds what were they
most basic
twisted pair and we talked about
unshielded and shielded okay
next up in cost and uh effectiveness was
calaxial cable which by the way is
sometimes just called coax
for sure right um not to be
not to be confused with coaxing things
like cook someone to do something anyway
um coax and then the last one was fiber
optics right
now uh when you think about this we said
that fiber optics
were the most awesome but also the most
expensive okay and so therefore the main
use of fiber optic cables is in
remember when you've got a lot of data
to transfer
okay and uh you need to have high
reliability so it tended to be
in backbones right now therefore
the vast majority of cabling
and wiring in networks is these two
okay now we said these don't transmit by
by using light they transmit by using
electricity and electrical signals okay
and what was the problem that that
introduced remember
alexander graham bell's problem and his
kind of solution what was it
good so both of these are open to
electromagnetic interference
okay that's it's like the very nature of
it okay so therefore
why are error checking and correction so
important and so crucial
in communication systems well
most of the communication systems run on
things that are very easily interfered
with
okay there are magnetic and electrical
fields everywhere in the environment
okay so that's why we've developed all
these different ways for checking
for errors okay